also um ehrlich zu sein hat sich jetzt
nicht viel verändert also nach wie vor
geht es es uns immer noch leider Gottes
schlimm man meint halt je mehr Zeit
vergeht desto leichter fällt es einem
aber ich finde eher der Gegenteil ist
der Fall also es ist je mehr Zeit
vergeht desto mehr vermisst man sie und
dann kommen jährlich je Geburtstage und
jetzt leider auch der Todestag was uns
halt am schwersten fällt einfach weil da
die ganzen Erinnerungen immer wi da
hochkommen und man kann es einfach immer
noch nicht realisieren was da passiert
ist also für mich persönlich ist es so
mein Leben ist in zwei Teilen aufgeteilt
worden es gibt für mich gar kein
einheitliches Leben mehr ich definiere
mein Leben gerade so dass es ein Leben
vor der Tat war und ein Leben nach der
Tat das ist Nadia meskin die Tat von der
die junge Frau spricht ist der brutale
Mord an ihrer großen Schwester im
November 20 wird benfscha mutmaßlich von
ihrem Ehemann Abdul Mohammed tuki
getötet die 34jährige Mutter wurde wie
so viele wie zu viele Frauen in
Deutschland Opfer eines femizids und als
wäre das nicht schlimm genug wird der
mutmaßliche Täter wohl niemals von der
deutschen Justiz für diese grausame Tat
bestraft denn der damals 41jährige tuki
flieht kurz nach der Tat nach
Afghanistan und kommt nicht zurück
Abdul Mohammed tuki wird seitdem vom BKA
gejagt zwischenzeitlich steht er sogar
auf der Europe's most wanted Liste von
Europol wie konnte tuki
entkommen das und die Hintergründe zu
dieser Tat hört jetzt in unserer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland mein Name
ist Stefan Netzeband und ich bin Mirko
Kasimir schön dass ihr auch heute wieder
mit dabei
seid
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild die Afghanen binfsa kommt gemeinsam
mit ihren Eltern und ihrer Schwester
1999 nach Deutschland benfscha wird hier
Mutter zweier Söhne im November 2020
sind die beiden 7 und 3 Jahre alt ihr
ältester Sohn ruid ist schwerbehert
bfcha und der Vater ihrer Kinder trennen
sich wer der Mann ist und wann die
beiden sich getrennt haben darüber
konnten wir bei unseren Recherchen
leider nichts in Erfahrung bringen
deshalb widmen wir uns jetzt benavschas
nächstem Ehemann Abdul Mohammed tuki
Abdul tuki reist 2010 nach Deutschland
und beantragt hier Asyl aber sein Antrag
wird abgelehnt erst als tuki im Jahr
2018 benavscha heiratet die einen
deutschen Pass hat und er
Erziehungsberechtigter ihrer Söhne wird
da bekommt tuki eine
aufenthalsgenehmigung er darf in
Deutschland bleiben doch gut integriert
scheint tuki nicht zu sein wie benfschas
Vater nach ihrem Tod gegenüber Bild
berichten wird spricht tuki schlecht
über die deutschen behauptet alle seinen
hier Ungläubige und er wolle zurück nach
Afghanistan benfscha tuki und die zwei
Söhne leben in einer Dreizimmerwohnung
im Südwesten Münchens diese ist in einer
großen Wohnsiedlung viele Kinder leben
hier im Sommer spielen sie Fußball oder
fangen im Hof so idyllisch das vor dem
Wohnhaus auch ist umso weniger ist es in
der Wohnung dieses Ehepaars immer wieder
ist tuki gewalttätig gegenüber benfscha
Anfang November ruft die 34-Jährige
sogar selbst die Polizei weil sie Angst
vor tuki hat am Telefon erzählt sie den
Ermittlern sie habe sich in ein Zimmer
eingesperrt weil ihr Ehemann sie bedrohe
daraufhin rückt eine Streife an das
Ehepaar behauptet dann jedoch sie
bräuchten keine polizeiliche Hilfe mehr
vielleicht ist gerade deshalb benfschas
Beziehung zu ihrer Schwester Nadia und
ihren Eltern so wahnsinnig eng die
Familie trifft sich fast täglich zum
Essen und zum Spielen jeden Morgen
telefoniert benfscha mit ihrer Mutter
damit sich die beiden zum Frühstück
verabreden
können aber am Morgen des
17.11.2020
bleibt benfschas Anruf aus und das ist
ziemlich ungewöhnlich für benfscha ihre
Familie macht sich Sorgen und wendet
sich an tuki dieser erzählt am Telefon
er und benfscha wollten einkaufen gehen
und dieses Gespräch wird das letzte Mal
markieren dass Familie meskin von ihrem
Schwiegersohn hören wird danach sind
benavscha und tuki verschwunden kein
Anruf wird mehr entgegengenommen keine
Nachricht
beantwortet hey ruf bitte an wo seid ihr
wir machen uns alle Sorgen bitte melde
Dich das sind nadias letzte verzweifelte
Nachrichten an ihre Schwester was sie
nicht weiß benavsa ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt bereits tot und tuki auf dem
Weg nach
Afghanistan noch am selben Abend meldet
Familie meskin benfa bei der Polizei als
vermisst eine geht in die Wohnung des
Ehepaars kann jedoch nichts
Ungewöhnliches feststellen und verlässt
die Wohnung wieder am nächsten Tag rückt
die Kriminalpolizei an überprüft die
Wohnung und entdeckt was man im
polizeideutsch blutantragungen nennt
also Spuren die von einer Verletzung
Zeugen es dauert aber bis zum nächsten
Tag dass benfschas und tukis gesamte
Wohnung spurentechnisch untersucht wird
durch den Einsatz von Luminol können die
Ermittler weiteres Blut feststellen und
gehen jetzt von einer Gewalttat
aus doch wo ist
benavscha die Antwort ist so beklemmend
dass man erstmal schlucken muss wir
fassen noch mal zusammen dreimal waren
die Ermittler bereits in ihrer Wohnung
doch erst am Freitag bei
Wohnungsdurchsuchung Nummer 4 finden die
Ermittler benfschas Leiche die 3-jährige
Mutter wurde erstochen mehrere
Messerstiche trafen sie in den
Oberkörper und in die Hand im Anschluss
brachte der Täter ihre Leiche ins
Kinderzimmer und versteckte sie dort im
Bett unter dem
Lattenrost Werbung so Mirko hier ist
jetzt mal ein Buchtipp angesagt oh das
ist eine sehr gute Idee ich suche
nämlich noch Weihnachtsgeschenke ich
auch mein lieber und ich bin
passenderweise auf eine coole krimmy
Reihe gestoßen oder jetzt machst du mich
aber neugierig na sag mal an ich schreib
gleich mal mit also alle Märchen Enden
gut alle Märchen
Enden nee Stopp das ist nicht der Titel
aber was würdest du denn zu diesem Satz
sagen alle Märchen Enden gut na ja den
halte ich eher für ein Gerücht das
stimmt doch gar nicht dass alle Märchen
gut enden genau das ist eine Lüge und da
sind wir beim Titel Rotkäppchen lügt
heißt das Buch und mit dieser Lüge
beginnt der Auftakt einer Thriller
Trilogie von Bestseller Autor Elias
Haller der kommt aus Moment Moment
Moment warte warte von der habe ich
gehört der ist Polizist oder und der
kommt aus meiner alten Heimat Sachsen er
kommt aus Chemnitz glaube ich und er hat
Bücher geschrieben über einen Kommissar
namens
Donner Erik Donner genau sehr gut du
bist gut Mirko Haller arbeitet seit 20
Jahren als Polizist und jetzt gibt es
eine Reihe mit der Sonderermittlerin
Nora rotmann vom Landeskriminalamt in
Berlin die stößt auf einen
Korruptionsverdacht rund um den früheren
LKA Präsidenten und dann bricht die
Hölle los wie ein blutdürstiger Wolf
zieht ein Killer durch die Hauptstadt
Berlin er fügt seinen Opfern
größtmögliche Schmerzen zu dabei
inszeniert er seine eigenen abartigen
märchenversion von Rotkäppchen denn
Rotkäppchen haben wir ja schon
festgestellt am Anfang Rotkäppchen hat
gelogen he Stefan das klingt wirklich
sehr spannend und nach einer guten
Inspiration für tatau Deutschland das
finde ich auch also Fälle in innerhalb
der Polizei sollten wir mal nach gucken
hier noch mal zum Mitschreiben
Rotkäppchen lügt der Auftag zur
grimtrilogie von Elias Haller ist am 10
Oktober rausgekommen und wenn euer
Interesse jetzt geweckt ist holt euch
das Buch gerne bei Amazon oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in unseren Show
nototes Werbung
Ende das ist tatsächlich unfassbar
viermal gehen Ermittler in die Wohnung
viermal durchsuchen Sie die finden sogar
eine Menge an Blut und die ganze Zeit
liegt benfchas Leiche nur wenige Meter
von ihnen versteckt unter dem Kinderbett
ihres Sohnes in einer Pressekonferenz
versucht der damalige Leiter der
Münchner Mordkommission Josef Wimmer
irgendwie zu erklären wieso benfchas
Leiche erst bei Durchsuchung Nummer 4
gefunden wurde hierbei müssen wir
vielleicht noch
Angaben oder Erläuterungen machen weil
im ersten Augenblick das vielleicht
etwas unverständlich klingt dass man
drei Tage später eine geschädigte Tod in
der Wohnung auffindet hierzu muss man
wissen dass es natürlich nicht wie in
grimiserien abläuft und ablaufen kann
sondern dass später im Gerichtsverfahren
jeder Blutstropfen jede
daktilloskopische Spur oder jede dnapur
entscheidend sein kann dies führt eben
dazu dass man nach dem ersten
feststellen von blutantragungen die
Wohnung verließ dann wieder mit
entsprechenden Experten langgierig und
gründlich die spurentechnische
Untersuchung vornahmen und dann am freit
schlussendlich eine gründlicheuchung
vorzunehmen in Hinblick auf Unterlagen
auf mögliche weitere Erkenntnisse zum
Aufenthaltsort zum Ablauf des Geschehens
weil ursprüngliche Zustand der Wohnung
war nicht erkennbar dass hier ein Kampf
stattgefunden hat und weil die Ermittler
benfschas Leiche es drei Tage später
finden gewinnt tuki eine Menge Zeit so
viel Zeit dass er seelenruhig in einen
Zug nach Italien steigen und von dort
weiter nach Afghanistan fliegen kann
aber bevor wir weiter über den grausamen
Tod von benavscha und tukis Flucht
sprechen halten wir hier mal kurz inne
und befassen uns mit speziellen
Einsatzkräften der Polizei denn durch
besondere Fähigkeiten von sogenannten
super recognizern kann tukis Flucht ins
Ausland tatsächlich einigermaßen
rekonstruiert werden super Recognizer
also auf Deutsch super Erkenner sind
Menschen die sich sehr gut Gesichter
merken und vor allem selbst in großen
Menschen Mengen wiedererkennen können
flüchtiger Kontakt ein unscharfes Foto
oder verpixelte
überwachungskamerauaufnahmen hat ein
super Recognizer einmal ein Gesicht
abgespeichert erkennt er dieses überall
wieder auch wenn es sich über Jahre
stark verändert hat bei
Ermittlungsbehörden sind super
Recognizer dementsprechend ziemlich
beliebt und werden immer öfter
angeheuert um bei der Verbrecherjagd zu
helfen Wissenschaftler gehen davon aus
dass etwa 2% der Welt Bevölkerung diese
Fähigkeiten besitzen um zu erkennen ob
man möglicherweise selbst ein super
Recognizer ist hat eine Londoner Uni
einen Test entwickelt den Link zu diesem
findet ihr in den Show nototes aber
zurück nach München zurück in den
November 2020 benavscha ist tot ihr Mann
und mutmaßlicher Killer Abdul tukii ist
geflüchtet wie schon vorher erwähnt
schalten die Ermittlungsbehörden super
Recognizer ein und tatsächlich entdecken
Sie tuki auf Überwachungskameras gleich
zweimal am Vormittag des 17 November
erkennen die gesichtsexperten tuki
zuerst auf Videoaufnahmen eines
Reisebüros wenige Stunden später
entdecken Sie ihn wiederum auf Bildern
die zeigen wie der 41-Jährige in einen
Zug nach Verona in Italien steigt nach
Angaben der Mordkommission fliegt der
von dort weiter nach
Afghanistan unmittelbar nach seiner
Flucht erlassen die Ermittler einen
Haftbefehl wegen Totschlags gegen Abdul
tuki außerdem leiten Sie eine
internationale fnung ein die Belohnung
für Hinweise 10 000 € aber ein
hartnäckiger Gedanke hält sich hätte
tuki schneller zur
internationalenfandung ausgeschrieben
werden und somit seine Flucht nach
Afghanistan verhindert werden können
wird der damals 41-Jährige nie zur
Rechenschaft gezogen weil benfschas
Leiche zu spät gefunden wurde denn in
Italien hätte tuki noch festgenommen
werden können in Afghanistan ist das
deutlich schwerer wenn nicht sogar
unmöglich die Münchner Staatsanwältin
Juliane Grotz erklärt im Interview mit
Bild wieso es ist so mit Afghanistan
besteht kein rechtsshilfeverkehr der
rechtshilfverkehr mit Afghanistan wurde
schon Anfang 2021 ausgesetzt daher
können wir dort keine pahnungsmaßnahmen
durchführen außerdem haben wir auch
keinen Ansprechspartner im Land dem man
sich wenden
könnte durch tukis Flucht fehlt Familie
meskin ja nicht nur die rechtmäßige
Bestrafung des mutmaßlichen Killers
ihrer Tochter und Schwester mit ihm sind
auch all die Antworten auf die Fragen
über benfscha letzte Minuten ihres
Lebens nach Afghanistan verschwunden es
gibt Momente da kommt es einfach in
einen hoch und dann weiß man okay was
gerade passiert ist und dann kommt kommt
wieder dieser Tag und man macht sich die
ganze Zeit dieses kopfkehino okay wie
ist es jetzt genau abgelaufen warum hat
er das gemacht war war das jetzt ein
Streit oder was auch immer da war was
hat sie dabei gefühlt das
Bundeskriminalamt fandet auch noch mehr
als 3 Jahre nach dem Mord an benfsa nach
Abdul Mohammed tuki falls ihr Hinweise
habt wendet euch bitte an das
Polizeipräsidium München oder an jede
andere
Polizeidienststelle beenden werden wir
diese Folge heute mit den Worten von
Nadia die auf eine so brutale Weise ihre
große Schwester verloren hat Abdul
Mohammad wie konntest du so unser
Familienglück zerstören wir haben doch
zusammen gesessen wir haben zusammen
gegessen gespielt gelacht wie konntest
du das den Kindern meiner Schwester
antun wie konntest du das meinen Eltern
antun mittlerweile weiß ich dass deine
Tat geplant war du hast Wochen zuvor
schon nach einem Ticket nach Afghanistan
gesucht und egal wo du bist ich ich
frage dich denkst du wirklich du kommst
mit so einer Straftat einfach so
davon und das war unsere heutige Folge
von Tat Deutschland wir haben mit
unseren eigenen Quellen gearbeitet die
insbesondere auf den Recherchen von
bildchefreporter Karl Keim beruhen die
Aussagen von Nadia stammen aus einem von
ihm geführten Interview aus dem Sommer
2021 bei Anregung oder Kritik schreibt
uns gerne eine Mail an
podcast@bild.de oder schickt uns eine
Direktnachricht bei Instagram wir hören
uns beim nächsten Mal bis DAH alles Gute
euer Stefan und euer Mirko macht's
gut dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Herrmann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland